want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get
seven amazing insights from elon musk
oprah winfrey and other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one take big chances with elon
musk i don't really
like risk for risk's sake or anything
it's and i do think that um
uh
early things are are very risky
uh with a low chance of success but
if you want to try to come up with an
innovative breakthrough
that's kind of that's going to be how it
is
anything
which is significantly innovative is
going to come with a significant risk of
failure
um
and um but you know if you've got to
take big chances in order for the
potential for a big
positive outcome um and um
you know just if and if i mean if the
outcome is exciting enough then then
taking a big risk is worthwhile
it's really
our approach but but then once executing
down a path i actually do my absolute
best to
reduce uh risk you know because
or to improve another way of saying to
improve the probability of success
because uh
when you try to do something that is
very um
very risky
uh
that you hate you you have to spend a
lot of effort trying to reduce that risk
as you embark down that path
i mean when
um when i started spacex the i thought
the odds of success were very low
um i thought we'd most likely
fail
but i thought well
we should give it a try nonetheless
lesson number two stand for something
with oprah winfrey so many people are
worried about building a brand i hear
kids on social media talking about their
brand
and i used to really resent the word
when people would say to me oh you have
this brand because i never never even
thought about a brand i just thought
about day in and day out making the best
right choice for me
but now i embrace it because i recognize
people see me as a brand
but for me it's not a business it is a
question of what do you stand for
and i will say this you're nothing if
you're not the truth
so i have made
i've made a living
i've made a living i've made a life made
a fortune really it's fantastic
all good
[Music]
from being true to myself
and that's the if i could leave you with
any message today that is it
uh the biggest reward is not financial
benefits though it's really good you can
get a lot of great shoes
nothing wrong with great shoes
but those of you who have a lot of shoes
know that having great shoes and a
closet full of shoes or cars or houses
or square footage doesn't fill up your
life
it doesn't
but living a life of substance
can
substance
through
your service your offering of your whole
self and the baseline for how do you
live a life of substance is whatever is
the truth for you what do you stand for
lesson number three empower people with
jeff bezos whenever you
empower people with new tools
you get unexpected and beautiful results
and that's that we're seeing that we're
i think we're still in the early innings
of seeing the kinds of change that aws
can bring to a whole group of
entrepreneurs including entrepreneurs
inside companies
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four retrain with
bill gates the motivational aspects
of
you know why do you learn many people
learn just to get a degree because that
is how you get a job
but how do you make things interesting
that's kind of an unsolved problem so i
do view
uh
you know retraining and education that
in order to deal with the dynamism of
this uh fast-paced innovation
that you also want to make equivalent
breakthroughs not just in automating
things but improving education and if
you could have one wish to improve one
thing in an economy
uh
you know education is kind of the master
switch of your capability there's a few
things like energy and stability and
trust that are important too but
education would be uh
right up there and yet you know if i say
to you oh the best math teacher lived 50
years ago he's better than any math
teacher since then you couldn't
disprove that that was right that is our
understanding of
how you draw kids in and how you
understand their misconceptions
is
it's it's very ad hoc the average math
teacher today is probably about the same
uh as 20 years ago
and yet you know if we can do agents you
know we're talking about the general
issue of being able to
read and and form knowledge the idea of
being as good as one-on-one math tutor
and seeing what types of conceptual
mistakes people make and even more
importantly understanding how you
motivate them
uh
to you know you keep it at the right
level or you create the right uh sort of
uh problem domain that they might be
interested in or you know some sort of
contest or draw a social aspect into it
that motivational piece is where you see
most of the variants it's not domain
knowledge uh
that
you know makes difference as we see
because that it's online and yet uh we
don't see much change so i am enthused
about that
whether that means that your learning
will be more episodic and you continue
to do it in adulthood you know that
would be ideal
uh so that even if the job market is
switching you're
uh
qualified lesson number five just be
yourself with mark cuban you have lived
your life as an iconoclast and in a way
that's a template for other people but
in a way it isn't so in other words how
much you've got an ordinary person
ordinary man or woman how much of an
iconoclast could you or should you be
like mark cuban oh i don't care just you
should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
thought or said i was just going to be
myself and
you know on my dad's son on my mom's son
i'm my brother's brother
you know um alexis alyssa and jake's
father tiffany's husband
this you know i just try to do the best
like everybody else i mean i've been
blessed
you know like i say all the time i'm the
luckiest guy in the world and i just try
not to take it for granted i try to
enjoy every minute and i think now as
i've gotten a little bit older i try to
give a little bit more back than i have
before and and try to help more people
and
i you know in terms of whatever if
anybody else finds himself in my
position just enjoy the moment enjoy
every minute of it i mean i guess my
question is are you a role model for
people in society
i don't know i mean
i never thought of it i mean it's not
something i try to be i just try to be
myself you know i just try to to
to help where i can do what i can
um be a good dad
and you know
i i i'm not trying to be something for
somebody else just myself lesson number
six don't fail to try with vinod khosla
when one is starting it's hard to say
what whether it'll be successful or not
if it's assured success
then there would be no risk
if there was no risk everybody would do
it and if everybody was doing it it
wouldn't be unique or innovative so
innovation
fundamentally involves risk-taking and
risk-taking means failure
i like to say my willingness to fail is
what gives me the ability to succeed
and too many people just are not willing
to fail so they don't
try anything new
i like to say
you should try and fail
but not fail to try
because the people who fail to try fail
to take risk fail to do something
attempt something new
are failing before they start they just
don't know it and lesson number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is study successful people
with grant cardone i made the mistake in
my life of studying people that
appeared to be successful
a lot of people are like that
they appeared to be successful you know
today today in the the the the times
that we live in you know you can go on
instagram it looks like
looks like everybody owns a ferrari
everybody has a rolls royce everybody
looks like they're having the best day
of their life that's that's not studying
that's watching
i want to study people
or even even at conferences you can go
to a conference and watch somebody on
stage and he couldn't he he or she could
present to like they're so successful
but if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot of talking
and so i would just
strongly suggest to people to
pick
a handful of people and make sure those
people are actually doing not just
saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day and how would
you know what they're doing
well you should you would you would see
it in their statistics right like
there's some things you can't fake yeah
you can't fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million worth of
real estate this month with my money
hard to fake that okay it's a great
instagram post by the way but you can't
fake it
there's going to be a loan there's going
to be a building there's going to be you
know acres and acres of land there's
going to be people living there like you
just can't fake it so there's a lot of
things you can fake you know you can
make a nice little quote put it on
instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and uh
the public is is
confused with a lot of what appears to
be the truth that's not that's right and
so i would just tell people
um study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing i would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them
lines up with where you need advice
right so warren buffett you know warren
buffett he he's at the he's at the he's
at the tail
um he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right
so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it he doesn't buy stocks he
buys companies yeah
uh so you gotta you gotta listen to
people steve jobs right here was one of
the most aggressive
business people that this plan has ever
seen i mean he was barbarian aggressive
so was bill gates but if you talk to
bill gates today bill and steve steve's
not alive obviously but
bill gates today saying dude i'm giving
all my money away money doesn't matter
that's not what he was saying right here
many times i've gone with what i thought
was fact and sometimes i thought were
pretty good hunches and i didn't do so
well but i'm very fortunate that more
than 50 of the time i did do very very
well and i'm finding out more recently
in my life the last couple years that
you try not to just think with your
brain but think with your heart how do
you feel about the situation how do you
feel about the people no matter how kind
they are and i've had some really nice
people uh got in foreign countries and
everything else that were the nicest
people in the world turned out to be
total rip-offs but i didn't know that
there were clues along the way so i say
to everybody and i say to myself now
feel the person out or feel the
situation with your heart what is your
instinct i think now more in life that i
go off instinct plus facts you obviously
have to have some facts along with it
does it become easier the more you do it
yup
much easier when you're when you're set
to well how do i feel about this shall
we say with data stable data that i have
how do i feel about these facts and then
and how i feel about it just my
intuition how do i feel about it from my
heart
and the more you think about doing it
that way the more it happens when you're
down and out first thing people do is
blame it on everybody else but
themselves
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook you also
have the responsibility of turning
things around when i started paul
mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident
and i started the company out of the
back seat of my car how were you at that
time 30 seconds that was 34 35 at that
time so you're homeless at 34 35 again
and what was this series of events that
led to that second time it was just that
we had money set up a half a million
bucks we need to start the company with
that kind of money and uh the day i was
ready to start go down the bank and get
the money my partner the hairdresser
paul mitchell flew over from hawaii with
his girlfriend and we were ready to get
the money and get going and get started
i'd left everything i did my
relationship wasn't working out so left
the house plenty of money for many
months with her had a few hundred bucks
in my pocket took the used car which is
20 years old but a decent one okay down
the hill to get the money wow i was
going to check into an efficiency and
all set up the money never came in no
way nev the guy changed his mind 1980 81
inflation in the united states is 12 and
a half percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate
17
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and interest uh and unemployment was ten
and a half percent the united states the
guy said you're his hostages are still
in iran which they were at that time he
says is this a terrible i'm sorry it's
the last minute no
so it's a matter of
what are we gonna do
the nice thing now that i'm
not uh so extreme in my 20s i i didn't
get to read
much at all and so like all this stuff
is going on in biology and math
i just didn't didn't get to read it then
when i did get into my 30s those
vacations were uh
a time to go back uh because when i was
a student you know you could study
all sorts of things uh
anyway
um
now
you know i read a lot of science uh and
that
uses up uh you know maybe half of the
slots uh
that that i have really understanding
u.s poverty and what's going on there
there's a a few dozen books that try and
give you a glimpse of that that are very
good this book factfulness let me say
you know it definitely uh
creates a framing
uh
for what's going on in the world and the
other one that's right up there is any
uh pinker book
starting with uh
better angels of our nature uh today the
greatest pleasure of your life is when
you're doing what is it other than being
interviewed by me or something like that
what are the great greatest pleasure of
your life
uh you know time with
kids
time with scientists a
time when i'm reading and things are
making sense
you know going out and seeing the impact
of the foundation's work
meeting with scientists who think we can
make breakthroughs to
help solve climate uh you know these are
super
interesting problems
and
you know having a broad set of system
thinking applied to these problems
is going to be necessary
uh to orchestrate the resources and
policies behind them so you know i love
i love my work and this is the thing i
think i have to just say
everybody is feeding yourself on
the hysteria and the negativity you
gotta stay in the light but one of the
reasons why i was so excited is about a
wrinkle in time because the message is
that the darkness is spreading so fast
these days you must become a warrior of
the light and the reason that's so
meaningful to me is because that's how
i've led my whole life and every moment
in that film i just felt like i'm just
saying what i've normally said it's true
and and for these times the darkness is
there to show you your light look at
what has happened so if you put the
focus on look at what happened with the
darkness that showed up in parkland and
the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson the darkness that
showed up in many many many many many
many homes in chicago with shootings and
uh senseless murders it brings out the
best in people it brings out the best
and so that's what it's there we live on
a planet where there is darkness and
light i teach them that there is no life
without
cultivating a spiritual life
because you are first and foremost a
spiritual being having a human
experience
and if you lose sight of that it's easy
to get lost in the world
and no one can save a world that they're
lost in when they've lost sight of their
own north star
so having a spiritual life actually
means actively and ritually creating the
space in your life all the time for
gratitude for kindness for empathy for
inspiration for joy and for reverence
for life in the home of your soul first
and then working to spread that inner
joy outward it means
slowing down it means taking in the
moment it means being exactly where
you are
not distracted somewhere else it means
knowing who you are and getting about
the business of fulfilling why you
really came to our planet there's a
friend of mine who's got a great saying
about creating a company um
which is
creating trying to build a company and
have it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then then reality sets in things don't
go as well as planned customers aren't
signing up the technology or the product
isn't working as well as you thought
and um and then that can sometimes be
compounded by a recession
um and uh
it can be
very very painful for several years um
so i think
um
frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance how aside from making
great products how do you get people
excited about tesla there's a lot of
people i know and that i talk to who are
just intrigued and interested and
excited about tesla as a company the
thing i really focus on at tesla is like
we really put all the money into an
attention to trying to make the product
as compelling as possible so um
because i think that really the way to
sell any practice through word of mouth
so if if
one somebody gets the car they really
like it they and and actually the key is
like to have a product that people love
um and and generally people
that um if that a party or tour friends
or whatever um you'll talk about the
things that you love
but you know if you just like something
it's okay you're not gonna care that
much but if you get the reactions from
the highs and the lows yeah you gotta
make sure you have a really good you're
gonna
you're to talk you know and and then
that'll generate work during word of
mouth and that's basically how how our
sales have have grown like we don't
we're not spending money on advertising
or endorsements or
uh and um so anyone like buys our car
they just bought it because they they
like the car and you know it's like it's
genuine there are a lot of things that
are a waste of time you know when you
think about your life i think i i often
tell people um that i work with
if you can get
because people people have very high
standards
for
how they want their work life to be
and uh
and i said look
if you can get your work life
to be where you enjoy half of it that is
a whole
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead that's reality
everything comes with pieces that you
don't like you could be a supreme court
justice and there's still going to be
pieces of your job you don't like you
can be a university professor and it's
still going to be you have to go to
committee meetings and you have to do
you know there are every job comes with
pieces you don't like and we need to say
that's just how that's part of it
and
and not resent those pieces or try not
to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird i think false
uh
idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress
it's your choice
and
so it's you have to figure out how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things and i find
people don't dislike hard work
what people dislike and what is being
out of control
like they can't control their life they
can't control their environment this
happens to me
when i get over scheduled
i hate being over scheduled
i want some time to be able to think and
free myself we all have the same amount
of time in the world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled you have this event you had to
agree to do this and maybe last night
you were like why did i agree to do this
i have to go on stage tomorrow i wish i
would really with my family and you know
or i hope maybe not this case let's say
that you like this one but in general
that kind of thing happens and so you
have to guard your time and um and and
try to save a little bit flexible so
that's for me it's not a waste of time
but i like to have some freedom of
movement
uh rather than having every minute of
every day
scheduled when you buy over the internet
amazon do you ever get the wrong order
is anything ever wrong what do you do do
you call up and complain or you don't
have any problems no i i
i i'm a customer of amazon hopefully
like all of you in this is there one
person full time there's services
in this room who's not an amazon
customer see me right afterwards and
i'll um i'll walk you through it it's um
i i yeah i get i have problems sometimes
and i and i treat them like
the same way i treat a problem that i
would get from customer my email address
is famous and i keep it and i read it
it's jeff at amazon.com i don't see
every email that i get anymore because i
get too many but i see a lot of them and
i use my curiosity
to pick out certain emails i'll get one
from a customer and there's a defect you
know we've done something wrong that's
the usually people are writing us not
always but usually the writing is
because we've screwed up their order
somehow
and i am
uh so i look at this and for some reason
something seems a little odd about that
one and so i'll ask the team to do a
case study and and find real root cause
or causes it's usually causes real root
causes and then real root fixes so that
when you fix it you're not fixing it for
that one customer you're fixing it for
every customer
and that process is um a gigantic part
of what we do so i would treat my if i
have a failed order or some bad customer
experience i would treat it just like
that today the 18 founders of alibaba a
lot of people think they are legendary
something wow you all hibaba founders
you must be super good at
honestly
most of us cannot find the jobs early
days
we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a
you know a great university
um
but the thing is that
we are ready to learn
we believing in the future if we work
together if we will learn with improve
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about that you
will be vp vice president right
you will always be a tiny manager in
your life
because if we're successful
people will high they will be smarter
than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us and then we'll be in trouble
right so when we're high people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
you will be happy because this is the
mission that we have
so
i will say there's no best people in the
world that is suit
ready for you
the best of people is always you you
find the right people
working together
training him developing him and he
training you he
then you have a chance to build a team
well when i went back to china in 1995
with an idea of internet was very
strange china was not connected to the
internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is internet nobody say
ah this thing never work this thing
never exists um
because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to
when i go to the china red
company registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo hope
internet
company
the guy looked at me and said
this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's no word called the internet why
you want a registered company called the
internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but
it i in 1995
in later
august china was connected the internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to
prove i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we
they just try to take the picture i i
die from hangzhou to shanghai shanghai
to america to connect the internet it
took us
three hours and a half to download the
first front of the page
at that time there is no netscape called
the mosaic
oh
so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my journalists friends to
stay and wait because to prove that i'm
not telling a lie when you get to my age
you will not measure
how well you've done by how much money
you've got i can guarantee you that
you'll all do fine on money anyway i
mean uh
you know think about it seven hours a
day
you know
you're in a bed you've got exactly the
same mattress i've got if you don't
whistle it to it the furniture mark you
know i mean so so that when we're on a
parody i can't i can't outdo you you
know in terms of my sleeping enjoyment
you can you can match it by buying this
mattress which we'll give you a special
price on just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a dairy queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat at mcdonald's and burger king and
and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place so our eating
experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a 10
year old car until about a year ago you
know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me and they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it you know we dress more
or less the same i mean i pay more for
my clothes but they look cheap when i
put them on so we're really on
we're on a parody yeah so so the money
isn't going to be that big a deal
everybody in this country is going to
you know that with the intelligence this
group has the energy you have you're
going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say
that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean you know
so i won't i don't want i'm not
shortchanging it i'm just saying you
can't do too much about that but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many
and extent whether it's the people you
want
at 70 or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end i
mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love i mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you buy
testimonial dinners you can buy your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things but the you know the only way
you get to be you know love is to be
lovable it's kind of irritating actually
got a lot of money be more fun to just
write out a check for a million dollars
so everybody you know from now on loves
me but it doesn't work that way and in
fact
it the only way is to be is to be
lovable and and you know i've got this
friend
who uh
who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and
what is it now it's uh
sixty years later
you know she still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself
in determining who she really trusts his
friends
the one question in their mind is would
they hide me
now when you get to be 70
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
you've had a successful life
i know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them i mean they
they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know
they they don't have anybody's respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something of the sort but they
they nobody loves them and
uh my friend tom murphy at campus cities
tv i mean dozens of people would hide
murph you know
all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know
that
ben graham a lot of people would have my
dad it would have had a number and then
like i say that i can i can tell you
people
that uh you know everybody
may pay homage to them and the kids may
put up with them and hope they don't
change their will or something but the
truth is that nobody would hide them and
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
when you get to be 70
you will have a very successful life
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that for example
communication skills i tell the students
that come that
they're going to
graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that if they
just learn to communicate better and
both in writing and in person they
increase their value at least 50 percent
and now i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and you have to be
able to get
get both your ideas and uh
and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i'd taken a shorter course
now in terms of my talking later on but
it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you we have a culture
that's very focused on um being very
focused on what we're building
so focus is a really important part of
it but it wasn't at google for a long
time now it seems to be in vogue so they
may be saying you know this the focus is
better but so
but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come and and add
their ideas i mean some of the best
ideas throughout the the company's
evolution
they have just been from just places all
throughout the company whether it's an
engineer or you know someone on the the
customer support team or just different
uh just different areas around the
company so we've always had these
hackathons right that are basically time
that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's basically an incubator for
people to prototype different ideas much
in the spirit of how facebook got
founded originally
the idea that you can build anything
good in a day or a couple of days right
and get a version of that running um so
you get it running you then test it
internally yeah and then we can see and
that that helps us shape the road map
and what we want to do in the future but
we also have a culture where we want to
stay very focused and um we don't want
to run with a lot of projects that we
don't expect to launch right so um so we
want to get a lot of ideas help have
those ideas shape where we want to go
and then execute in a very focused way
on the stuff that we're going to do but
i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us and one
which i talked about before is just
moving fast right the whole company is
really optimized around someone joining
um being able to
build something very quickly be able to
launch it quickly
iterate very quickly on that the first
set of schools that we launched at after
harvard were schools that had other kind
of school specific social networks so i
think it was stanford had something
colombia had something
and i think yale had something so i
think why did you choose ones that had
school specific social networks because
i wanted to competitors well i wanted to
go to the schools that i thought would
be the hardest for us to succeed at
because i knew that if we had a product
that was better than everything else
that other students were making at other
colleges then it would be worth
investing in and putting putting time
into but i didn't want to just kind of
like get into a project where there
would end up being this huge legacy of
maintaining it if ultimately there were
just going to be different things that
were as good as it the process of me
cutting the feet out of my pantyhose
while trying to get the prototype made
before i launched it was two years so
there was a year solid of me driving in
north carolina on the weekends and at
night or taking time off from work to go
and work on the prototype get it made i
learned so many things that i didn't
know as a consumer it had never dawned
on me you know that men were making all
of our undergarments so i learned very
quickly that the industry had been
taking an average waistband size between
a small
and an extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working
we're really uncomfortable and they were
doing it to cut cost and production so i
immediately changed that in a spanx
waistband a size small gets a small
medium gets a medium and so on makes
perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord inside the
waistbands that had been there forever
well we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so i
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing i learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go
ask her how she feels
[Music]
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother my grandmother who's 90. my
sister-in-law cassie i mean all of my
friends the girls at spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
spanx garments and how they made you
feel why is that important i know that
as part of the spanx training boot camp
one of the mandatory learning modules is
comedy that every employee has to go
through so why is that important i
wanted i didn't understand why
why everybody was so serious
so i thought you know what i don't
subscribe to the fact that you have to
act serious to be taken seriously
and i like to laugh at myself i you know
i looked when i worked in corporate
america for a long time and everybody
was super uptight and super serious and
there was no humor and there was no
levity and then everybody at like five
o'clock became ragingly hilarious i was
like what what's going on like you know
and so um the alcohol probably helps at
five you know but but but anyway i i
wanted to um to use humor and i love to
do that in the workplace and yes we have
a boot camp at spanx a training boot
camp when you come on board and one of
the modules is doing stand-up comedy and
i've used the comedic
stuff that i did in my marketing i mean
i wrote don't worry we've got your butt
covered right on my package when i first
started in 2000 which was not very
common to do especially taking it to the
neiman marcus to sell it i named my
company spanx which was you know made
people laugh and believe it or not it
was very shocking at the time that i
named the company spanx i actually had
people hang up on me often
i would call them and say hi i'm sarah
from spanx and then they'd hang up and
i'd call back and i go i'm serious i'm a
real company and my company's called
spanx
and they go oh i thought you were prank
calling me um
so um
and then you know naming my products i
broke into the world's most boring
category i mean can we talk about
shapewear who wants to talk about
shapewear and undergarments but
it was i named it power panties you know
i started naming all my products and it
made people laugh and it gave so much
energy and then all of a sudden you had
gwyneth paltrow and julia roberts
flashing their spanx on red carpets and
saying i'm wearing spanx like all these
celebrities and i think it's because i
chose to do humor and people wanted to
participate in that there was energy
around that
um so
so i use it in in every aspect of of
the marketing
i use humor to turn around a situation
when i'm bombing it it might give me a
second chance when i cold called to sell
fax machines door-to-door for seven
years i learned very quickly that if i
could make somebody laugh or smile i'd
get another 30 seconds before they'd
slam the door in my face
there's just it helps you move through
pain
it's it's a wonderful tool what industry
you think still requires a lot of
innovation
all of them
seriously i mean look
one of my dad's favorite sayings was you
don't live in the world you were born
into
everything changes all the time and you
know what's better than change creating
change and so whenever i see something
that's done the way it's always been
done
you know like when i got to the mba
you know my whole goal is just to have
things up right because they everything
was done the exact same way they thought
they were in the business of basketball
for 50 years they thought they were in
the basketball business no you when you
go to a basketball game you don't
remember the jump shots the dunks you
remember who you were with the fun you
had it's one of the few industries when
that ball is in the air at the end of a
game
everybody holds their breath and you're
if it goes in you're hugging people
you've never seen before you you know so
you can take any industry and look at
the way things have been done and try to
come up and innovate and you know and
like i said with just the nature of
capitalism right now all the changes
that are required
every industry needs change and there's
a unique opportunity that i don't think
any generation has ever seen the first
question you're going to get asked when
you go to apply for a job whether it's
now or some point in the future is what
did you learn what did you do what
skills did you add during the pandemic
of 2020 and i think it's imperative to
anybody looking to to get a job to
really push themselves forward to do
better than their parents to really
place a focus on learning you know i i
think you'd agree mike and anybody
watching that one of the greatest skills
that we all can have in the in the
business world is a thirst for knowledge
just being excited about learning and
knowing how to learn and this really is
the best opportunity ever for people to
add to their skills whether it's taking
a coursera class or you know in the past
i would have said reading a lot of books
but now having learned from my kids
going on youtube and you know watching
um tutorials and watching videos on
various subjects you know i learned how
to write a three-letter three-layer
javascript neural network on youtube
and so there's a unique opportunity now
for you to add skills particularly in
areas like artificial intelligence that
are going to be in great demand that
most people have not yet learned because
you know it's it's so recent that it's
become really applicable sometimes it's
like god has other plans it's like
something hits you and you don't even
know and well frankly the things going
through my mind were what's you know
what's what's going on what's wrong with
me uh i would try i would spend my
makeup trying to cover it up because
rosacea is bright red and you get these
um patches on your skin and they're
textured like sandpaper like a rush
right almost yes and it's very textured
and so um no i mean i think any time
you know something happens to us whether
it's a physical thing a physical change
an emotional
situation um something with our health
right any time we have something like
that you know the the
it's hard
to go through the the beginning of it
because i struggled a little bit
honestly i had thoughts like okay
am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed never even
said that out loud by the way but like
that's the truth i just started doubting
myself i started um
doubting okay is this going to affect my
career you know but
in in the midst of the the start of kind
of that that i guess struggle of going
okay
my physical appearance is changing let
me wrap my head around this um uh is
when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on on uh
every product i could get my hands on
from the most expensive to least
expensive and and there's that famous
saying like you know sometimes we make
our mess our message and that's sort of
what happened it was this
entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem and there must be
so many other people that have just
given up on makeup because it doesn't
work for them and it's like okay
nothing works and and
the more i researched i'm like wow
seventy percent of women have hyper
pigmentation wow
all of us yeah yeah that's like oh you
know what i mean and so many of us deal
with just all different uh things
hormonal changes everything acne and so
i just thought you know what
if i can solve this problem for me i
know that it could be you know of
service and life-changing for for other
people also is there any daily
disciplines that you have in your life
daily routines that you would attribute
to your success
uh
yeah i try to beat the sun up
uh i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
um i live two two minutes from my office
so when i bounce out of here i gotta go
do a live a live stream on real estate
but but uh
yeah that that's the first three things
if i can get that done in the morning
man i know i'm gonna have a good day
yeah pretty simple b to beat the sun up
make sure you write down your goals yeah
make sure you take care of yourself get
the blood flow and get the heart pumping
yeah and i goes down fresh a new unit
like in a new unit of time like i've
written down today like i had never
written them down before nice
yeah
that's um so so so simple on the outside
but so many people won't do
those
three
i dare i dare everybody listening here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you can even make seven you mentioned
that
whilst writing 10x raw something changed
for you yeah yeah
what was that was it was that sort of
this look the 10 actual to going all in
or no the 10x world was it was just the
awareness of i had been dependent upon
one vertical
right and i'm sitting there looking okay
i worked my ass off
uh i i was good at my craft
i saved my money
what did i do wrong here dude
51 years old
i should have
i should be like so rich right now
i got i mean i should be like not even
huh where's my get ready i wasn't even
thinking about injecting right i wasn't
even thinking about jeff i should just
be like
i was still having to do business with
people i didn't like
i'm like why am i still kissing asses
and i don't mind kissing asses like i
don't mind i'll do whatever it takes but
i'm like
why am i still flying three million
miles every three years like i was
banging miles down i went 150 000 miles
a year wow you know away from my family
like like my life was miserable i'm like
it's fine that you do that for 20 years
it's not fine if you do it forever
and
i'm like oh my god dude i wasn't scaling
now i didn't know that until the economy
um basically served up the lesson right
all right we're gonna take your three
businesses
and we're gonna show you that we you
really only have like maybe
a half of one business
took took the first business and just
cut it in half took the second business
took it down to like 90
like just killed this partner i had
and the third business was real estate
and it was frozen it was literally like
they put it in a freezer and said you
can't you're not going to lose any of
this but it's worth nothing to you today
yeah and i was a life support
and i'm like i'll never do this again i
will never be dependent upon
one vertical one partner
or a handful of real estate
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want seven more
amazing lessons from billionaires check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you should just
be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm quite grumpy
[Music]